the adventures of helmeted hero slash
galaxy's best
foster dad and his green-skinned
50-year-old son
shall continue yes the hit disney plus
star wars series the mandalorian is
indeed returning for a second season
and here's all the details we have on it
who will be returning for season two
pedro pascal's mando real name din jaren
carl weather's grief karga giancarlo
esposito's moff gideon
gina carano's cara dune and of course
the child
aka baby yoda will show up in the new
bundle of mandalorian episodes
get ready for season 2 of the series to
add new characters to its ranks as well
some of whom star wars loyals have
already seen on the silver screen
when mandalorian creator john favreau
confirmed the debut date for the new
season back in december
he added to his announcement tweet a
photo of a gamorian
a species of piggish creatures who
guarded jabba the hutt's palace in
return of the jedi
this hints that the series which is set
five years after return of the jedi
and 25 years before the force awakens
may take a turn into territory not yet
charted by the star wars franchise
to boldly go where no one has gone
before whoops wrong franchise
anyway season two might dig into the
goings-on of jabba the hutt's crime
rings and how they've been getting on
following his death
perhaps amanda will find himself a new
big bad foe to face off against when he
meets a brutish gamorian or maybe he'll
have to escape the wrath of one of
jabba's closest associates
deadline later noted that the upcoming
season of the mandalorian is set to
include a variety of characters from the
skywalker saga
that is the nine star wars films that
stretch from 1977's a new hope all the
way to 2019's the rise of skywalker
in the outlets words insiders have
hinted that
several established characters from the
skywalker sagas feature films mythology
will make appearances during the show's
sophomore season
this could account for characters as
relatively low-key as
droids as well as for major players like
dare we say it
the famous mandalorian bounty hunter
boba fett
who many believe was the person
approaching fennic shan's dead body at
the end of chapter five
the skywalker saga left a lot of
questions unanswered so perhaps the
upcoming season of the mandalorian aims
to patch up those blank spaces
and bring viewers face to face with some
not so forgotten characters
in february 2020 it was reported that
wwe superstar sasha banks would also be
joining the cast
pro wrestling sheet soon confirmed the
story and while it remains unknown who
exactly banks will play the star does
make an ominous appearance in the first
trailer for the series second season
slash film confirmed in march 2020 that
rosario dawson had been tapped to play
ahsoka tano the
jedi padawan apprentice of anakin
skywalker who appeared in both star wars
the clone wars
and star wars rebels in season 2 of the
mandalorian
this will mark the first time the
character has been performed in a live
action production shortly after that
announcement it was confirmed that
aliens actor michael bean joined the
cast to play
quote a bounty hunter from the
mandalorian's past
timothy oliphant and katie sakhoff are
also joining the series this season
the former will play cobb vance the
ex-slave from the star wars aftermath
novel trilogy who acquired boba fett's
armor
the latter will reprise her clone wars
and rebels animated role of bogotan
crees
the one-time ruler of mandalore and
current head of the mandalorian night
owls collective
the well of knowledge regarding the
mandalorian season two's cast may have
provided some worthwhile insight
but here's where there's a juicier cache
of information available to mandalorian
enthusiasts
in a move that surely delighted fans
everywhere the series season 1 finale
didn't end on a cliffhanger as far as
the core story goes
instead it planted the seeds that will
grow into the season two narrative
mando's about to embark on a new mission
a two-member one
with baby yoda serving as his plus-one
this was signified by the armorer
etching a symbol into his suit
and telling him to look after baby yoda
as if he were its parent
i would kill or die for you
that'll make up the heart of season two
even more so than it did season one
leaving any subplots to the writer's
discretion well
except for one there's a huge dangling
thread where maf gideon is concerned and
surely the new season will address that
internet-breaking bombshell that came in
the final few seconds of chapter 8.
you know the one that saw moff gideon
wielding the darksaber the black
lightsaber created by the jedi order's
first ever mandalorian inductee
tar vizla yeah those ones it's very
plausible that the second most important
storyline for season two will center
around
maf gideon his motives his backstory and
things of that nature
disney being disney the company is
keeping its mandalorian season two
secrets closely guarded
and anything that will fill the spaces
in between moths mandos and baby yoda's
respective arcs is a pretty big mystery
for now
however disney released a full length
trailer for season 2 that offers just
enough
out of context teases to get everyone
speculating about what it has in store
a mysterious hooded figure a possible
hint that mando will meet some jedi
mando's ship the razor crest looking
like it's facing impending doom
distinctive landscapes and glimpses of
banthas hinting that a return to
tatooine is in the cards
and a blink and you'll miss it moment
that teases someone in boba fett's
helmet and armor
the season 2 trailer featured all that
and more
it cleverly didn't answer any of the
questions fans have going into season 2
but it certainly hyped them up even more
than they already were
and really what more could they ask for
prepare to head back to the galaxy far
far away when the mandalorian season 2
hits disney plus
on friday october 30th check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite star wars characters are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one